and here with more is the house
oversight committee chairman James comr
All right a lot of breaking news tonight
uh was a new subpoena issued or did they
just agree to comply with the old one we
issued a new subpoena because we wanted
to make sure everything was done right
the old sapena had an old date so we
make sure every eyes dotted and teas
crossed and because we've done this
investigation the right way we're
getting everything we wanted we wanted
hunter Biden to come in and answer
questions we have a lot of questions and
now he's going to have to come in and
sit down and and answer specific
questions about specific transactions
specific meetings uh he's going to have
to answer to uh interviews that we've
conducted with some of his former
Associates and we're going to see what
level of involvement Joe Biden had in
these Biden family
schemes well well let's talk about what
do you think the odds are that he's
going to want to plead the fifth and his
attorney ABY L is not going to let him
say a word that's a possibility correct
it it is a possibility but look they've
been saying they've been doing all these
publicity stunts saying they wanted to
uh get the truth out they wanted to to
speak publicly well all right you're
going to come in for this deposition
you're going to have an opportunity to
answer questions Hunter Biden's going to
have an opportunity to defend his good
name and if he pleads the fifth and and
refuses to answer the questions I think
the American people can assume that this
family has been on uh on the take for a
long time from our enemies around the
world so we're going to give Hunter
Biden due process he's going to come in
but I think at the end of the day this
is a huge victory for the house
oversight committee this is exactly what
we wanted and Hunter Biden learned that
when you do things the right way uh that
you don't get to uh make your own rules
we're treating him like go ahead Sean
you you're treating him like you like
everybody else I got it um all right so
it it's it's going to be interesting I
don't know how you explain away a phone
call uh uh just 5 days before his father
goes to Ukraine when he's in Dubai
meeting with barisma Executives barisma
Executives on the phone with Hunter and
Joe Biden and that's when Joe Biden
later bragged about leveraging a billion
taxpayer dollars uh to get a prosecutor
fired because that was their big problem
and they needed DC help the prosecutors
fired and Hunter who admitted he had no
experience in energy oil gas Ukraine
getting paid Millions at a time when
he's addicted to drugs on top of it um
so uh that answer I would look forward
to hearing I'd like an answer on that
wouldn't you yeah and he's going to be
asked that question he's going to be ask
a lot of questions about China and
Romania what exactly did you do to
receive the millions and millions of
dollars that our enemies around the
world sent you what was the purpose for
that money and if they going to you know
if they're going to continue to play the
loan card uh are you going to pay the
money back uh when you you we heard from
Kevin Morris today Hunter Biden doesn't
have a job he doesn't have any assets he
owes Kevin Morris at least 5 million
if not more we learned that today and
and according to what he told the bank
he owes China over $5 million uh the
loan total with Hunter Biden and Jim
Biden now as as I calculate is $15
million we don't believe they're going
to pay any of this back I mean these are
serious ethical issues and tax evasion
issues that the Biden are going to have
to answer to well I mean I was listening
to Jamie Rasin let's be honest I mean
he's really just a political hack um but
the idea well this was just a small
percentage of his net worth uh $5
million and uh but wasn't it given at a
very critical time uh leading into the
2020 election this could have been a big
campaign issue if in fact hunter in uh
had not paid his taxes wasn't that money
the original money used to pay T back
taxes yes it was and I think that's very
important we had an email today uh
courtesy of the IR s whistleblowers that
showed that that uh Kevin Morris sent an
email to the accounting firm saying
we've got a huge political problem here
this is in 20120 during the presidential
campaign Joe Biden versus Donald Trump
we've got a huge political problem here
and the political problem was that
Hunter Biden hadn't paid his taxes and
the IRS was fixing to card him off and
that would have been very damaging to
Joe Biden's presidency we believe that
was a campaign Finance violation we
believe that that the purpose of that of
that money was to save Joe Biden's
political career and and look Kevin
Morris just met Hunter Biden and five
weeks later he's paying his IRS tax
bills uh that's about the time of of uh
from the time Kevin Morris met Hunter
Biden to the time when he paid the first
installment to the IRS for what Hunter
bide knowed that doesn't seem normal and
for Jamie raskins to try to explain that
that's okay I think is a bit of a
stretch even for Jamie you're asking and
I guess he was is a fan of Hunter's art
cuz didn't he purchase some of the art
uh did you talk about that did you ever
talk about the fact that Hunter as far
as we know doesn't have a job any source
of income had I I if you give that much
money uh my understanding is you're only
allowed to give somebody I believe
$115,000 after that it's taxable right
uh so if it's a loan doesn't it have to
be on paper is there a paper trail uh is
there interest payments that have to be
made as well is there a payment schedule
repayment schedule he said he had all
that but because he was also Hunter's
attorney he couldn't disclose that so
here's a guy saying he's his attorney
and he's loaning him all this money and
in California I don't believe you're
allowed as an attorney to loan your
client money lots of ethical questions
here lots of tax evasion questions yeah
yeah all right big breaking news
February 28th uh Hunter Biden goes in
well done
James comr house oversight committee
thank you sir hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else